le 15 décembre si nous sommes bien
arrivés autour des 5000 contamination
par jour et environ 2500 à 3000
personnes en réanimation
nous pourrons alors franchir un nouveau
cap
un cap loin d'être atteint et une
inquiétude qui gagne l'ensemble des
français à la preuve des fêtes suspendus
aux lèvres de jean castex ce jeudi si la
france s'attend au pire
le seuil des 5000 cas pour enclencher un
déconfinement place le gouvernement face
à un casse tête
première hypothèse la date du 15
décembre pourrait être repoussée bien
sûr que ça fait partie des hypothèses
nous sommes descendus très vite et nous
avons atteint un rythme de croisière
d'environ 10000 contamination par jour
tout allait pour le mieux
et depuis une petite semaine le nombre
de contaminations ne baissent plus dans
notre pays plusieurs raisons
probablement au fait que la baisse est
diminuée un relâchement des français et
la baisse des températures
l'autre option étudiée très sérieusement
par matignon et l'elysée durcir les
conditions du couvre feu étendu de 17
heures pour terminer à 7 heures du matin
les restrictions concernant la culture
pourrait également rester en place à
partir du 15 décembre le gouvernement
pourrait décider de ne pas autoriser les
cinémas et salles de spectacles à
rouvrir c'est ce qui est mis sur la
table aujourd'hui je ne le souhaite pas
mais c'est possible
la question est de savoir comment
protéger au mieux les français la
culture menacée tout comme les
transports les déplacements sur le
territoire devrait être permis pour les
fêtes
mais il n'est pas possible que les dates
d'autorisation soit plus resserré que
prévu entre les régions face à ces
possibles nouvelles mesures
les français sont plutôt mitigés
al'approche d'un noël qui ne fera pas
comme les autres
[Musique]
ça me nettement s'illusionne me casse un
petit peu les pieds et j'ai envie de
voir ma famille que j'ai pas vu depuis
le début l'arrivée du cloud ide en
france et que concrètement j'ai pas
forcément mais de mesures plus que les
années précédentes
c'est vrai que cette année c'est encore
noël particulier d'habitude on le fait à
donc avec mes tantes mes oncles ma grand
mère mon grand-père qui ont plus de 80
ans mais bon il comme ils disent que
c'est peut-être le dernier noël pour eux
bah je pense qu'on va tout mettre en
place on va respecter les distances
sociales
on va pas manger la bûche de notre côté
mais voilà on va les mettre en bout
table on va faire attention à pas les
toucher et on va quand même passer un
noël en famille parce que c'est
important pour nous sacrifier les fêtes
de fin d'année pour éviter un
redémarrage puissant de l'épidémie voilà
tout le problème que doit résoudre
l'exécutif reste à savoir si les
français qui ont déjà fourni de nombreux
efforts seront prêts à accepter de
nouvelles restrictions